welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz and we're
back with another unique and special
edition of the podcast because today i'm
really excited to be joined by ellie and
jesse from sauce breaker and in this
episode we are going to get an insight
into what it's like to take your
recruitment career into a brilliant
business like source breaker a
recruitment tech business
and i've been talking a bit about the
career opportunities at break a sauce
breaker or one of the partners of the
podcast so i thought it'd be a fantastic
idea to actually get it from people who
actually work there on what it's like to
work there what the opportunities are
and what that transition actually is
like so ellie i'm gonna come to you
first if you could introduce yourself
for those that may not know who you are
then jess i'll come to you after and
then we'll
get through the questions that we've
worked on together
cool yes so i'm ellie and i'm a member
of the enterprise customer success team
at source breaker so i've been with
sourcebreaker for two years now um in a
senior position and prior to that my
experience is in tech recruitment so i
specialize in placing developers into
high growth london startups and so
love it that's a little bit of a
background
yet
hello i'm jesse
i spent just over three years in
recruitment and that was across
technology and finance and obviously an
overlap of fintech as well and then i
made the the bold move into software um
and i don't think i will ever look back
at breaker for 10 months now started in
the height of the pandemic um to now
being in a absolutely manic busy and
energetic office love it
so where i want to start and then we'll
talk a bit about how you both ended up a
sauce breaker but there's normally
always a bit of a story
so jesse i'll um come to you first how
how the hell did you end up in
recruitment how did that happen
so i am a born and bred recruiter to be
honest so
i've always been passionate about
fitness i wanted to go into the fitness
industry and my uncle's own a
recruitment firm okay and they basically
grabbed me and was like you need to be
in sales come into the office have an
interview i walked into this office you
know i was 18 years old loved the
ambiance loved the energy loved the
sales floor had an interview there
obviously smashed it got the job
but all of it being family it was too
much of an easy win so i said thanks but
no thanks um and i went to a competitor
and
yeah where i kind of learned all of my
skills and flourished and then
eventually went to the family business
and then yeah ellie what about you how
did you uh end up in recruitment
yeah not a born and read recruiter
jesse um so for me i was i was at uni
and i wanted to move to london
pretty instantly like she stood for my
uni house straight into london
had no idea what i wanted to do after a
degree and
spoke yeah i know literally
i don't know
and then i spoke i literally spoke to a
recruiter um for advice and we kind of
spoke through some options and i was
like i kind of like what you're doing um
how do i how do i do that and so um
yeah kind of same story as jesse just
went in absolutely loved the
you you really do get a buzz when you
walk onto that floor everyone's on the
phones everyone you can just feel it and
i absolutely just loved it so
that just happened for me um pretty
easily just kind of
first conversation with the recruiter
decided that that's kind of what i
wanted to do and then
let's sort of segue this then into like
so both obviously then ends like i think
what's crazy rise when you don't i've
suggested maybe a bit different for you
but when you don't really know
much about the recruitment world and
then you like come across it's like oh
my god how did i ever not know this like
existed or like this was an option and
stuff like that right so yeah obviously
then obviously i joined a recruitment
company and then obviously you found
yourself joining sauce breakfast so talk
to us a bit about that ellie like where
did the
i don't know maybe first sort of uh
things come up for you in terms of like
oh i could actually
take what i've learned in this first 12
months of recruitment into a business
like sauce breaker like how did it come
about you joining a tech business like
sauce breaker
yes so i had a really unique
um insight into startup businesses kind
of recruiting into startups that was
literally my entire market
and so whenever we go and see clients
again it's the
the
environment of a startup is so different
you can just see everyone has like
there's
people doing mind maps everywhere like
everyone just seems to be shouting
across the office you can see the
collaboration going on um and i just
kind of thought that's that's where i
want to be i want to be working in one
of these offices and
being and actually speaking to the guys
that would be moving into
these businesses these developers and
explain to them you know you're gonna be
wearing loads of different hats and
i was i've sold myself i guess on
joining a tech business so
reached out to a recruiter classic um
for some help getting into one of these
businesses um
and now i'm in a position where i can
utilize all the experience that i've had
from recruitment
um and then deliver and kind of one
thing i really enjoyed about recruitment
was having those
building those strong relationships and
maintaining them and that's something i
can still do in my current role so kind
of best of both worlds because
it is quite intentional in the world
yeah yeah
very intentional to join a startup so
i'm definitely because i'm curious to
find out what sauce breaker looked like
when you first joined but just before i
find that out jesse what what about you
then so obviously
was born to be a recruiter
uh and all of that so like where did
this sort of first i don't know where
did the inspiration come from or like
how did you end up joining sauce broke
out of interest
yeah so
i as much as i loved recruitment whilst
i was in it the emotional side of it and
anyone who's who's in recruitment will
agree you know you're dealing with so
many different dynamics and all of them
are people emotions and i think i got
very much invested um in the sense that
with the candidate i'd be there after
every interview
and when they didn't take the job or
they didn't get the job i think i
personally i took it personally um but i
love sales so it was finding something
that was as fast paced as that but
taking out an element of of the emotion
and you know so that's how i decided
that i wanted to be in tech sales um and
then yeah source breaker um
was almost meant to be because i love
the recruitment industry as we know um i
wanted tech sales
and i've got that
bars in that um pace but you've got one
element that doesn't have an emotion and
that is the platform yeah yeah
so it can't talk back to you yeah yeah
for sure and i get that so
okay so i mean there's a few things that
i really want to uncover with both of
you but just just quickly on this point
jesse specific for you what would you
say
is like
like so if me and you are down the pub
right now i work in recruitment and
you're in tech sales i think it seems
like quite a lot of
um
people that worked in recruitment are
actually taking their career into tech
sales from what i can see
um
like what how would you what would you
say are the main differences like
obviously it's a product so they're like
that's different but like what what
would you say are the main differences
that you've learned that maybe
people don't realize or that maybe
you've been surprised by out of interest
on the sales side
i was actually saying this um to ellie
earlier we were having a conversation
about it but it's the level of
engagement you get okay because you're
speaking to people and when people say
cold calling and business development
you think it's going to be you know very
mundane smashing up the phones but the
majority of my bd time is spent engaging
and speaking to people because number
one you're calling like-minded people so
you know sales people are going to want
to chat because number one um they
understand and appreciate what you do
and number two try and stop a
salesperson from speaking
so i think that the
main surprise for me was yeah how
i don't want to say easy because that's
not the right word but um
how
how
on
there we go
yeah you're not having to fully bang
down doors you're just tapping and there
you go okay hello all right
okay cool so fair enough so it's more
how willing people are to have
conversations
yeah okay interesting um
so ellie
talk to me about like
so what did like just because it would
give us a bit of a picture of like the
journey and then we'll and then i'm
interested to sort of hear your take on
how you transitioned i know it's
intentional for you but like what so
what did sauce breaker look like when
you join them
yes so
do you know what it's it's not too
dissimilar now despite the growth
when i joined it it's just the people i
think make sauce breaker and we've we've
kept a lot of the people that are there
that would here when i first joined
pretty much every single face is a
familiar face to to then as well um
it's
it's when i joined it was in a kind of a
place where
there it wasn't small enough that no one
knew what they were doing you know
start-up phase where it was right at the
beginning
and we're i guess we're kind of in the
same position when
there are processes that are in place
but there's so much opportunity to
introduce new ones update the processes
improve them just like not just
necessarily just talking about processes
but everything that we do
um
you can you can literally impact i
joined in my first couple weeks like if
i had an idea i was heard i was
listening to things that i said were
being like valued and that's one of the
most important things about sauce
breaker is that every single person
can literally impact the success of the
company like no matter what how junior
or senior that you are and that's
something that is still part of source
breaker now despite having bigger teams
there's loads of new faces in the office
today uh which is so nice um but in
terms of kind of what it looks like it
it hasn't changed too much in terms of
the culture which is it's just so so
nice um we're just more established
which is kind of in the market and with
the kind of clients that we're working
with so
for you then what we're like so
obviously it's quite intentional for you
to join source breaker and go into more
sort of startup tech business
what were what was that because i think
that sort of yeah
what i think recruiters would be most
concerned about or my curious about like
what what was that transition like going
from working recruitment to them working
in a tech business like what may be some
of the challenges or what are some of
the things that you again most like
surprised by out of interest
yes so
biggest positives for i guess from
moving
into
into customer success particularly but
also source breaker is that i'm just
going to say that the people of
sourcebreaker like the people are and
any startup i think is what makes the
business and everyone is just incredible
um
a lot of the skills that you develop in
recruitment as well so for me sales
isn't something that like i was
naturally born with the gift of um and
that
those those sales skills i developed in
recruitment are
pretty
um essential for my role now and so i
can still develop and use those skills
but just in a bit of a different way um
which is which is really really nice so
it is a it's a familiar market as well
so
you feel
whereas when you're in recruitment and
you're when i was talking to developers
and about the tech market it's not
something that i'm i was like super
super passionate about or knew loads
knows about when i went into it i know
so much about recruiters and what their
day-to-day looks like and what they're
doing that i can speak confidently and
like with kind of like authority on
what's going on which is which makes it
more enjoyable
um so overall it's been really really
good i think some of the challenges like
from going from recruitment into i i
think yeah both customer success and a
tech startup
is that in recruitment kind of leaning
on what i was going on
what i was saying before is a lot of
those processes sure are very
established in
you do this then this then this and this
and this is a proven method and this is
what works like you just kind of follow
things by the book basically
when you join a startup there there
isn't that
at all um so when i joined sourcebreaker
we had an enterprise customer success
team that was brand new and we were just
kind of going into specializing into
different clients and there was no
processes in place that were like
tailored and specific to those types of
clients
um
so that can be quite challenging i think
going in from kind of following
everything by the book to then having
kind of free reign and
decide like being able to make decisions
but like not necessarily i'd never done
customer success before um and so it's
something that was definitely a
challenge but we're now in a position
where we've got we've got like a
market-leading process that i've
you know helped build without having any
prior experience and it's like oh my
gosh i've actually i've done a lot of
that like that's amazing um
and that's i feel like that's not
something like everyone could say in
like much larger businesses and that's
one thing that i absolutely love that
makes sense like yeah you're gonna have
to be quite open-minded i think and be
willing to be flexible but as you said
the positive is that you can really
be involved in the creation of these
things or like like yeah be really
involved basically yeah yeah yeah
basically okay
love that
so um jesse
in terms of sales and so you said like
like how much you've enjoyed it or it's
been a bit yeah being pleasantly
surprised but i guess
like how how has having that recruitment
background and then like i saw obviously
recently you obviously progressed to an
accounting exec
so congrats on that so like thank you
how how has how has like
experience helped you excel in your role
do you think
i think that number one i've actually
used the product right myself
um so having actual hands-on experience
hands-on wins and a genuine passion for
the results that it drives when i'm
speaking to people it's it's coming from
the heart and i'd like to think that
that's well received from
um the
prospective clients as well but also
i appreciate how it's going to be used i
appreciate from a consultant's
perspective why um it's going to be
beneficial for their day-to-day but also
having had um you know dealt with a ceo
in a recruitment firm telling me what i
need to do and how to do it i can see
how it would then fall down and be
beneficial for them um and just in
general
the the the pain points i i relate to it
so it's just yeah it's i think that the
best way to sell is understanding your
client and having that pre-knowledge uh
to the point where i've actually been in
their seat um is just extremely
beneficial yeah so yeah like
like yeah it's enabled you to like
really like we all have to understand
who our target customer is and like
really understand the problems and
challenges that our products or what
we're trying to solve so that it's
really enable you to really grasp that i
guess a lot more quickly than maybe you
would if you were to go into selling a
different product where you hadn't used
before or you hadn't been yeah before
basically
okay and when you kind of come up
against potential objections yeah you
are responding to them having fought
them not with other clients but actually
sat and seen that those aren't
necessarily going to be an issue and
that the benefits of source breaker
far outweigh any potential objections
that people could throw yeah got it
so ellie curious
what what are recruiters
like as customers
good question
i genuinely have the best
clients i know genuinely i've like say
for example today i've spent five hours
of my day speaking to
recruiters from junior to senior and
also speaking to their managers and
their managers up to the you know the
directors of these businesses who are
investing in this tech every single
person that i speak to
is genuinely like well
i work with enterprise businesses so
a lot of them are much bigger and they
they sometimes have a lot of like junior
or greener recruiters and everyone is so
eager and i don't know if this is just
source breaker making my life a little
bit easy potentially and you know it
does wow people but the engagement that
we get is amazing um
and i think the important thing that i
always have to remind myself is is that
recruiters are so busy like if i take
myself back to then if i was told that i
had to take an hour out of my day to go
on training with a tech company i'd be
like absolutely not you know i don't i
don't have time to do this but because
we're genuinely able to add value to
their day and we're showing them how to
do their processes quicker
like i'm not
i'm i have to remember yeah i'm actually
adding value to every second of that
call so it's um
i have i have had a really good
experience i absolutely asking in my
class i absolutely love my clients i
think they are the best yeah they and
they're and they're really amazing
actually a driving source breaker
internally
that's one thing that they do is they
kind of tee up
the sessions they're like guys like
we're investing in this tool and then
the team are excited when they come on
and when they see by the time they see
me
they're already raring to go and excited
so i'm in a very advantageous position
it just makes me good
to be honest um i
can imagine jesse's experience on the
sales side where they haven't already
bought the product is a little bit a
little bit different to mine but from my
perspective from customer success
they've already invested
you do get
the i think the most challenging um
kind of people to deal with uh those
recruiters that have done their top
billers they've done their market for
the longest period of time and usually
in those cases that they've they've got
really good ways they've got a little
process of what works for them
and so my job in that instant isn't to
say okay well you're going to do this
instead it's to say okay we're already
doing this how can i make that process
already doing quicker and like try and
embed it into their day-to-day and so
that can take a little bit more time
which is expected but that's probably
the most difficult and the most kind of
pushback yeah yes what about you so you
said obviously you've got the advantage
of
understanding them but let's be real
here like what what can be some of the
difficult challenges and i've got my own
experiences like i sell a learning
development service to like the people
that you're speaking to are probably
going to be saying that i'm speaking to
so i've got things that i can share but
what have been
where can sometimes recruitment
customers come how can they be difficult
or what have you experienced so far
i'm not just saying
but i
genuinely never right
the more challenging a call is
the more of a buzz i get and i enjoy
when you've you're dealing with the big
characters and i even will turn around
on a call and i'll turn around and be
like do you know what you're really
challenging me here and then i'll thank
them at the end of the call
but what you've got to understand is at
the end of the day these are people
and
it's just a bit of banter sometimes so
you've just gotta
kind of break those barriers um but for
me i'd say the main challenge
from
my
as in my position
is actually doing the demos because i'm
not the most tech savvy and while
sourcebreaker is a very user-friendly
product when you're live on a
demonstration you know you you could
sometimes like forget how to type or
suddenly just completely lose what that
element does and you've got to kind of
bring it back and it's obviously live
and you're selling at the same time
and so for me the most challenging thing
is when demonstrating the product making
sure that you're selling the benefits
rather than the features
um and just overall yeah speaking and
typing at the same time yes like that
yeah i get that obviously i've
obviously done my recruitment mentors in
it like i've never before never demoed
anything so like i know
you like end up you sort of work out
like you try things don't you like you
sort of work out what lands what doesn't
like yeah it's it's yeah i get that that
makes sense i think some of the things
in my experience is like so i had it
today uh yesterday for example because
you're dealing with salespeople
like i was on the demo actually and i
was i basically
just was trying to pre-close him
basically
and he was like you're trying to
pre-close me aren't you and i was like
yeah i am it's a lot i think it's just
like that's the thing that i find quite
enjoyable and different is like these
people if they if they spend time on
their own development of sales or
whatever like they can see what you're
doing
do you know what i mean like there's
like
it's so it must be so difficult selling
to someone who knows exactly but like as
jesus said
most people will have a laugh of it and
i go yeah you're completely right i'll
be honest with you this is probably the
most effective way of me closing people
so that's why i'm doing that so like you
you just have you can have a laugh of it
and you can talk about it and as just
said they actually most people will
appreciate it
um
so yeah fair enough love that so let's
just talk a bit about so in terms of
like
what what have both of you i know we
sort of touched a bit on this but like
from a career aspect as we come to the
end here like for you ellie what have
you been you may have touched on already
but like what have you been
like really positively surprised with in
terms of like
your career opportunities and like how
things have progressed for you outsource
breaker out of interest like what jumps
out of you
when we think about that
yeah so
for me
um
how do i i don't know so i guess when i
first started i i had no idea of
anything about customer success and
it was it was mapped out pretty
straightforward of what i needed to hit
my next promotion
and so i was like okay so i just
did
what i was you know i wanted to get
promoted i want to climb the ladder i
want to be successful and for me my
promotions have been consistent
and happened quite quickly and it's just
been really really nice and it just so
happens that when you're in a startup
as teams grow
opportunities come into those teams so
we had a customer success team and then
that got divided or divided into you
know targeting different clients and
that kind of enterprise team that i'm in
now is going to be
targeting you know it's going to be
split a different way and it's like okay
well we need to we need a lead for that
team is that there's new opportunities
that come up all the time like that i
didn't even know existed when i first
joined source breaker like
these some of these teams didn't even
exist when my manager um joined source
breakthrough
number seven or eight in the company
like there was just a customer
there are success which is just yeah
yeah i love that the best thing what
about you jesse obviously as i said
release you got promoted like what have
you like what's been positive from your
standpoint but obviously recruitment one
of the big reasons why people go in
there is
it's the progression right which a lot
of the time if you're in the right
company there's nothing holding you back
beside yourself which is one of the
great things about working in the
industry so
what have you been really positive like
how do you feel about the positive
opportunities you've had and progress in
your career yeah
um so there's very kind of clear
targets in place it's like you know if
you get to this point then we're going
to move you up to that so it's working
towards that and knowing if i make x
amount of deals and hit x amount of
money you know that you're guaranteed to
get to your ex
so
you're constantly
motivated
but then also you know
personally i think i will be in sales
forever but being in a business where
you have an overview of so many
different
um
teams to and the opportunity to work
cross-functionally because think about
it in recruitment i've my experience was
at 20 to 30 man businesses where you've
got your consultants you've got your
directors and you've got your ceo but
everyone's a recruiter so coming into a
business like this you have the
opportunity to understand how customer
success are going to work with marketing
and you you're more involved with fine
ads when it comes to you know contracts
and things like that so actually seeing
how a business piece is together um
obviously recruitment is a business but
the way that it it flows is very
different yeah just seeing that there's
loads of opportunity if i did decide one
day that sales wasn't for me
um i could be housed somewhere else yeah
i hope
ellie would have me in customer success
yeah i love that so we'd have so before
i ask you both the final question
um
i guess like ellie so like what what can
you give us any inside scoop mate like
what's go like what's exciting what's
exciting resource breaker like what's uh
what's what's coming around the corner
like why is it an exciting time the
sauce breaker working there or like just
as a whole like what what's uh what's
coming for people yeah
i love that question um so
that's not exciting i don't even know so
we've i guess first of all the fact that
the
covert 19 has sparked this huge kind of
the tech industry is booming right now
particularly in recruitment i'm working
like just as a kind of example of this
i'm working with some businesses that
prior to lockdown or paper 19
their tech stack was you know email and
spreadsheets
and
you know knocking on doors of businesses
like it it's changed now people have to
approach this a different way and so we
we have a huge demand internally from
one man bands in the middle of scotland
all the way up to you know your biggest
recruitment agencies across the uh
across the world actually um that need
this tech and they need it to keep ahead
of their competition
and that's what we're giving people um
in terms of like internally at source
breaker and like what's going on
here there's there's like product
developments which are really really
cool um i'm someone that didn't know
anything about the products i was kind
of leaning what jesse was just saying
and i am very i love it i'm very into
that um which are i can't don't know how
much i'm allowed to say on this podcast
but it's very exciting and it's gonna be
a game changer um and actually
in within source breaker the
opportunities that we're hiring for
right now
literally span every single team from
sales to customer success to marketing
to tech to product so
pretty much any skill set think that
people have like we want to see
relentlessly
um you know
determined people that are rich do you
just want to make an impact and that's
the best thing about source breaker for
me i'm probably repeating myself but
when you when you come into
sourcebreaker
you we can see the company vision every
morning every monday we we know exactly
what we're working towards and i know
exactly what i need to do to make a
difference to the company i know if
whenever a client of mine is renewing or
they want to bring on more licenses that
is directly impacting the success of the
company like i can see what i've done
over the last two years like that's
insane to me to be able to impact a
company that has been recognized as like
one of the fastest growing companies in
europe like i was thinking about this
yesterday
that's insane that i've i've actually
done that and i don't know how many
people outside of startups can say that
that they've been able to do that and so
obviously like we i love source breaker
and i think we're one of the best
companies i love my job
but kind of outside of all of that
there's just so much more that's
exciting that's going on okay you know
so jesse what would your advice be then
for anyone considering like a
move transition into rec tech from your
experience jesse what comes up for you
and ask you that yeah i'd i'd definitely
say go for it and particularly with
sauce breaker if you get your
applications in now you'll be in just in
time for our christmas party and there
ain't no party like a sauce breaker
party um but in all seriousness where
sauce breaker is in the time that i've
come in i'm part of a well-reputed
company that's still small enough that i
can take make an impact but i can see
the vision and i know that everything's
about to absolutely skyrocket and to
shadow what ellie said you know i'm
going to be a part of that which is just
so exciting so yeah definitely have the
conversations you wouldn't you won't
look back you've got that recruitment
culture and all of the benefits of it um
and so much more yeah nice i love it
well
ellie jesse it's been an absolute
pleasure
thank you so much it's been uh yeah it's
been for having us really fun obviously
for anyone that wants further
information what's more of an inside
scoop before
they decide that they want to check out
sales break as a career option obviously
you can connect with uh jesse and ellie
on linkedin but yeah a lot it's been
great partnering with you um guys and
i'm really excited to see where the
business is in another year two years
um so thank you so much for uh joining
us
thank you so much
thank you for having us